super food dazu zählen beispielsweise
acai beeren shazam weizengras und quinoa
diese produkte gelten längst nicht mehr
als reine nahrungsmittel sondern als
lifestyle produkte denn sie machen
schlank und schön schützen vor krebs und
geben den extra energieschub wenn ja
wenn man der werbung glauben mag doch
stecken tatsächlich superkräfte in
diesen nahrungsmitteln oder wird das
resumee am ende des videos vernichtend
sein ihr habt euch dieses thema bei
whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
alle facts bei klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen thema gibt es am
ende des videos den link sowie zepter
könnt darauf klicken dann könnte ja auch
themen vorschlagen die hier ziemlich
schnell umgesetzt werden
die acai beere kommt aus südamerika und
ist viel mehr als eine unter vielen
wehren denn sie macht schlank beugt
wegen ihrer antioxidantien falten vor
und gibt einen extra energieschub vor
dem sport am besten kombiniert man sie
mit shazam echte alleskönner schon die
mayas wussten vor 5000 jahren dass sie
aufgrund ihrer gesunden omega 3 und
omega 6 fettsäuren besonders gesund sind
auch die avocado die gut für das
immunsystem die haare und die haut sein
soll gehört in dieselbe reihe und ich
könnte ewig weitermachen aber ihr merkt
es selbst das hat alles eher wenig mit
wissenschaft zu tun dafür sehr viel mit
werbung und geldmacherei doch fest steht
mittlerweile hat das so genannte super
food nicht nur die biomärkte und
reformhäuser gestürmt bitter weil er
kann man ja sagen und alles andere auch
im discounter bekommen und noch mehr
gefühl jedes zweite produkt sei es ein
gewöhnlicher müsliriegel oder eine tüte
saft ist mit dem begriff superfit
gelabelt und ja es stimmt das wird viel
zu oft als werbezwecke missbraucht was
ist wirklich dran an diesem star
lebensmitteln fest steht jetzt schon
einmal super food ist meistens extrem
teuer
und da es sich meist um exotische
lebensmittel handelt sind auch die
weiten transportwege nach deutschland
ökologisch gesehen eine echte
vollkatastrophe mit nachhaltigkeit hat
das nicht im geringsten zu tun ja wie
wird super fit wenn eigentlich definiert
es handelt sich um nahrungsmittel
achtung zitat die größere mengen an
vitaminen mineralstoffen protein
sekundären pflanzenstoffen und
essentiellen fettsäuren enthalten
das schreibt die ärzte zeitung und der
medizinerin mediziner wird super und
allerdings eher kritisch gesehen und das
hat folgende gründe oft gibt es keine
vorgaben bezüglich der hygiene bei der
lagerung in den herkunftsländern zudem
kann superfit wechselwirkungen mit
anderen medikamenten haben goji beeren
beispielsweise verstärkten blutverdünner
bezüglich kia samt wird empfohlen nicht
mehr als 15 gramm pro tag zu essen denn
es ist erst seit kurzem als neuartiges
lebensmittel in der eu zugelassen zu
leben haben tests wie beispielsweise der
zeitschrift öko test ergeben dass viele
super woods mit schadstoffen belastet
sind allen voran schimmel oder pestizide
und das auch bei den getesteten
produkten in bioqualität aber was sagen
studien zu dem so oft postulierten
gesundheitsfördernden effekt es gibt
tatsächlich untersuchung die bestimmten
superfit kandidaten positive effekte zu
schreiben demnach können china sahen bei
der gewichtsreduktion helfen da sie
einen appetit zügeln effekt mit sich
bringen können
dies hatte eine studie allerdings mit
nur 77 übergewichtigen typ 2 diabetikern
gezeigt eindeutige effekte auf
kardiovaskuläre risikofaktoren wie zb
hohen blutdruck ergaben die hier sagen
dagegen nicht spannend dagegen ist der
vergleich mit leinsamen wenn man nach
studien geht denn diese samen bremsen
steigenden blutzucker in ähnlich hohem
maße wie fasan und genau das empfehlen
viele expertinnen und experten heimische
produkte wie eben leinsamen oder
haferflocken solchen super co2 azzam
oder kino vorziehen
denn schaut man sich die jeweiligen
mikronährstoffe an dann sieht man dass
es keine großen unterschiede zwischen
super foods und heimischen produkten
gibt auch in nüssen pflanzenöle neben
leinsamen sind omega 3 fettsäuren
enthalten wie eben auch in der in den
teuren sparsam nicht nur die acai beere
sondern auch in den meisten blauen und
violetten früchten und gemüse arten
finden sich antioxidativ wirkende
inhaltsstoffe heißt also mindestens
genau so gesund wie avocado und alle
weiteren gemüt
arten und früchte sind brokkoli
aubergine grünkohl rote beete heimische
champignons heidelbeeren oder schwarze
johannisbeeren expertin experten
schreiben vor allem brokkoli aufgrund
seiner antioxidativen wirkung krebs
präventive eigenschaften zu also
krebsvorsorge eigenschaften und da
gesunde menschen in deutschland nicht
mit vitaminmangel zu kämpfen haben
meinen medizinerinnen und mediziner das
normale ernährung völlig ausreicht mehr
noch super fit sei überflüssig
auf der anderen seite schadet sporadisch
verzerrte superfit sicherlich nicht aber
viel wichtiger es ist auch kein ersatz
für eine ausgewogene ernährung dazu die
verbraucherzentrale hamburg
zwar spielt die ernährung eine wichtige
rolle für gesundheit und wohlbefinden
doch positive wirkungen hängen nicht von
einzelnen speziellen lebensmitteln ab
die auswertung einer großen zahl
langfristig angelegte ernährungsstudie
zeigt vielmehr dass nur eine insgesamt
gesundheitsorientierte ernährungsweise
positive effekte zeigt hiermit erkläre
ich also zum überflüssigsten produkt des
monats das super gut wenn er als erstes
neues zum thema ernährung zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video vorab garantiert der
können dort direkt in der redaktion vom
krieg zum mitmachen und themen
vorschlagen oder generelles der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das womit genau
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit
dafür draufklicken bauernhöfe ohne tiere
vegane landwirtschaft der zukunft an
sonst würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran